it's one of the most emblematic missing
persons cases in modern mexican history
the forced abduction and disappearance
of 43 students from the ayotzinapa
teachers college on september 26
2014. but not all remains have been
found all 43 are presumed to have been
killed
in the weeks and months following the
students disappearance the calls for
justice from family members and
survivors who managed to escape grew
into a nationwide movement
felipe de la cruz a father of one of the
survivors became a leader in the
movement he says after seven years of
activism the calls for government
accountability have only grown
personally and as a victim because i am
the father one of the survivors i don't
believe i will ever rest until we have
truth and justice and until those who
are responsible are punished because 43
families continue to suffer the torment
every day and night of not knowing where
their children are
demonstrations commemorating the
anniversary of the students
disappearance are now held every year in
mexico
for some the work of demanding answers
from the government has become a
full-time job
manuel
one of the students who escaped has also
been one of the loudest voices of the
movement
after years of protesting against the
government today he serves as a lawmaker
in mexico's congress seeking to reform
policies related to cases of torture and
abduction and place more responsibility
on federal officials in cases of missing
persons
i never imagined i would be here
let alone involved in the social
movements
my family in the town where i'm from are
never involved in social movements
because it's an area largely controlled
by criminals and people don't usually
speak up
following a botched investigation in the
case of the missing students and
evidence linking their disappearance to
members of the mexican military and
federal police mexico's president andres
manuel lopez obrador established a
special commission to find out what
really happened
mexican authorities recently announced
that new forensic evidence has opened
another line of investigation in the
case of the ayotzinapa 43.
and every year mexico's president
continues to meet with the family
members and survivors of the massacre to
personally update them on the ongoing
investigation as mexico marks seven
years since the disappearance of the 43
students mexican president andres manuel
lopez obrador will update family members
and survivors on the status of arrest
warrants that have been issued against
federal officials who are believed to
have participated in a cover-up of the
missing person's investigation
since records began in 1964 mexico has
recorded more than 91 thousand cases of
missing persons despite a massive social
movement and continuous efforts to
reform the law it's clear the country
still has a long way to go to truly
address the challenges linked to forced
disappearances
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city